hello ladies and gentlemen welcome to
multiple players I'm your host Chris
Waters here to multiple play games with
these guys uh these guys are Maxwell
McGee hello uh Alex new house hello and
Eric Tay what it do hey guys uh we're
playing lethal league today which if you
folks don't know about it it's like uh
like I feel like people say it's a Pong
fighting game it's sort of reference I
was wondering where you were going to go
with that cuz I have trouble describing
it's fighting game where you don't
attack each other you attack the one
ball that bounces around the screen in
order to make it kill the guy that
you're fighting against so uh it's
something that's a little bit better
seen you it'll be instantly
understandable so Alex and I are going
to start out with a little scrub League
uh face off cuz we uh a are not super
great at fighting games and B one of us
doesn't even work here anymore so
exactly and the answer may surprise you
uh so we're going to do a little free
freefor all there's five characters in
this build here uh and they each have
some basic abilities but we're going to
have Maxwell and Eric do some shout
casting and describe what's going on
here oh great as we uh we kick it off uh
so basically you have a jump you have a
hit and then you have sort of a a Parry
we like call a Parry so there's a
neutral ball and he tries to hit it
around now because uh Alex the
skateboarding dude hit it last if it
hits me boom I lose a life what do you
call those yeah we'll call yeah we'll
call
you lose a a stock believe we are
playing in stock mode right now with a
10-minute time limit um but yeah
whenever one player hits the ball you'll
see the ball changes to that player's
color and I like to call it basically
it's in that character's possession um
and if the ball is in your possession it
will not damage you it will only damage
the other
players I think that might have been
special that might have been so I asked
I asked Tim in the chat what Sonata
special move does and she says or he
says once uh her special has been
activated you can change the direction
of the ball in
midair I'm not mean if that like if you
like steer the ball that's how it works
or maybe you like hit it and then it can
like go straight up or something mhm
we'll have to we'll have to just have to
experiment already somebody in the chat
asking can you straight not punch each
other no you cannot you can run up to
each other and like try yeah you can try
to do that I guess we can like Clash a
little if your attacks Collide you'll
bounce off but if you just like yeah see
you just hit each other nothing happens
you have to knock the ball into the
other player ah man now you can there is
a bonus there's a caveat you can hit the
other player after they've been knocked
out when they go all black and white
like that there you go you can Style on
them a little bit take out the trash
clean house a little bit after the
round's over got to take out the trash
you got to take out that trash just get
a little
smelly what I hit that dang it all
right and sonata's getting work too
aggressive with these getting in at the
moment of contact Sonata Sonata much
like lck the the actual reptile in the
reptile games she seems to have a slower
startup to her swing whereas uh switch
and Raptor are much much quicker on
their startup swing so each character
has sort of a different Arc of attack
some are more vertically oriented others
are more horizontally oriented so you
kind of have to know the particulars of
your character they also all move a
little bit differently like uh switch
he's on a skateboard he can like
skateboard up the walls and along the
ceiling and stuff Sonata I maybe can
double jum if I remember correctly yeah
she can double jum okay she can double
jump I can kickflip people want to know
who's playing who again real quick Chris
is playing a Sonata and Alex is playing
as switch and they both have one life
left so this is the big decider right
here again Alex is switch Chris is
Sonata the girl with the giant hammer
theill right into it come back and a
shot for the win you also gain levels
and level up but I'm not really 100%
sure what that does I think it it it'll
unlock additional colors for us but I'm
not sure what else it'll do the game is
this game is still we should also
mention very much in development this
isn't even like an early access build
this is the build they sent me uh that I
saw at Evo so it's still a work in
progress there are things that are not
done yet let's do a quick rematch and
then we'll get another player okay all
right let's play as latch I'm going to
play as after AKA straight up baseball
homeboy I'm playing as Gator play Ghost
version latch latch is currently my
favorite his uh he does have like the
longest setup to his swing but he has a
huge swinging Arc so he can cover a lot
of the screen you just have to know the
timing of it whereas a raptor is just
really quick he has a he's sort of like
the the most balanced I guess of the
roster he's got a pretty quick swing and
it has a pretty good Arc oh my goodness
um and he can also R wow all right well
Raptor can jump off the wall um whereas
latch can like climb up the side of the
screen yeah like that and you can attack
while you're while you're hanging on to
the side of the screen as well get him
off the screen on good move I'm just
going to hang
out oh all
right people asking about what the
meters represent so as you see up at the
top there's like the the larger life bar
which is divided into eight sections
that's basically we're playing on stock
mode right now so if you think of like
Super Smash Brothers when you knock
somebody out they lose uh one of their
one of their
lives the same thing is sort of at work
here um below the stock meter though
there's a four section uh energy bar
because it's a fighting game we have to
have some kind of energy bar for people
to play with um and so there we go so
Alex there very good timing showing off
just what uh you can do with your super
bar when it's full when you have all
four sections full each character has a
different uh special attack they can
perform
by double tapping the x button when they
hit the ball and apparently mine was
catching it yours is to gobble up the
ball and then you can I think you hold
down X and you can just walk around with
it in your in your mouth and then you
can uh what is going on you can spit it
out to different parts of the screen get
out he's like counter hitting you after
you hit it that's why right next to him
I know what is literally happening ER
okay all right just just in case that
was more of a that was more of a like
emotional slap slap the face tail or
with my
rather terribly sorry gobu Riot you do
have a name you were one of the people
who asked a question earlier
oo so just so everyone knows the pink
right the pink is when he's pairing and
it slows down yeah we didn't you want to
explain parrying no uh I mean you go for
it Panic total panic all right so
sometimes you guys would have seen uh
somebody hits the ball and it turns pink
for quick slows down it loses momentum
it just pops up we call that parrying um
basically what you do from there is that
when somebody pops the ball up in the
air and it turns pink if you hit it
after that you get two sections of meter
and there's very little hit pause
there's very little uh well there's no
other way to describe it like when you
hit the ball sometimes you'll notice
there's a pause and like the screen
shakes and it gets all dramatic and then
the ball takes off and starts shooting
around the screen if you parry the ball
first and then hit it that delay is much
shorter so you can kind of mess with the
timing catch people off guard that way
all right rubber mat and you build up
you build up meter faster latch again oh
C scrub League rubber match real quick
I'll play a switch again all right I
don't even know I've never played as
Candyman playing the best best two out
of three huh Chris yes all right sounds
good he got the most Swag yeah oh my
goodness they're in a run down swimming
pool Candyman oh God candy man is super
real this game the Candyman spash where
he uh hits the ball and it goes through
the screen to the other side of the
screen
Nast thing it's so nasty also he's got
that swag run he's got that style look
at that look at that nonsense that
Candyman Shenanigans Candyman is real
he's so
Shenanigans can you run up the wall man
uh I don't know what candyman's special
movement thing is besides looking like a
feel he's a little like his turn around
isn't as quick he might have well I
don't know if he has faster move speed
than anybody else though I know his
legs cuz like switch fast too okay oh no
okay hold I'll catch you now get in
positions 3 2 1
go be it makes sense all right uh this
is your ball it is yeah it's anybody's
ball once once the ball it's like the
ball is guarded for like the first
second or two when the match starts I
see but then after that it'll it'll go
to neutral and anybody can hit
it oh God Dam the SL roller yeah oh yeah
yeah do the splits oh what what yeah
Dodge it that's
right
no oh wow that get him off the stage did
not time that right
oh oh no it backfired chrisy I got my SP
Styles also I hope we get show but like
later on when the when the ball starts
going at ludicrous speeds around the
screen the uh head shot across the game
has all these different Distortion
effects that will start to that it will
start to apply you guys will see it soon
my go move right there yeah pretty
good all right clean it up later clean
it I got to come back
here
oh
little one life cross it up cross it up
yellow Sanchez chat oh no asking what
platforms is this game coming out on
right now I believe it is just coming
out for steam one of these guys cuz your
hands are gross but they're not going to
rule reptile isn't going to rep rule out
other platforms just yet it's just steam
is what they're working on right now
it's sort of their focus steaming in
hard all right I'm sure they would love
to release that on every single platform
Under the Sun Let's get someone else in
oh let's go three let's get three
players you want three okay that Max
monitor yeah somebody want to take the
laptop away from me sure I'll take the
here you go I'll check out chat I'll let
you Max and or Max and uh oh we see all
right let's have Max and T face off yeah
you guys you guys you guys got this you
want some candy man use your own
controller that my sweaty one you got
you got back out I got look I like to
preserve the Integrity of my sweat layer
on my
own want to share speciic level of claim
ph balanced for a chis yes what stage we
not seen oh we did oh sorry it's all
good I just figured random was so I'm
playing I'm playing as latch he's the
pro Gat Eric is playing as op Candyman
op
please all right well [__] oh God oh
God insane speeds when you keep I'm not
red okay I'm going to have to remember
that Chris I saw you going for the
strategy of just hitting it back and
forth to yourself yeah so you can gain a
little bit of momentum so you can then
cuz then you if you can like Bounce It
Off the Wall a little bit yourself you
can sort of control the ball for a
second and you have a good idea of what
speed it's coming back out at and you
can just keep uh increasing the speed
that way yeah and then you can try to
Rocket it out at some
unpredicted difficult to predict angle
nightmare let's go where's it going to
this time the par can't know where C
from Candyman
is oh you're like those you like those
next level in mid swag I was trying to
swag you were swagging too hard that is
called oh no oh no oh no I wasn't paying
attention that's how quickly can candy
man uh his special of course is the one
where once you you've got it charged up
you can it'll go wall and wrap around oh
nice Parry there what woo you got style
you got nothing no come behind me so the
Parry does the Parry interrupts the
momentum but it also SW if you hit a
Parry it Al Auto it switches it to your
color right yes you don't have to follow
up with the hit necessarily yeah once
it's been pared anybody can hit it and
it'll immediately go into their
possession and if the Parry period ends
the person who
pared possession that's an interesting
question Hold On Let's test that I want
to test that don't hit the ball don't
hit the ball here we go so I'm going to
Parry it and we'll see wait for it to go
neutral wait for it to go neutral okay
so your Parry does hit me I got hit by
hit it and then and then if I just let
it go I get hit I do get hit yeah it
happened to me earlier okay convers
convers that thank you Max that didn't
work Oh I thought that was just
game oh yes dead though
question my goodness C you're just
letting him do the oh no oh nice catch
Jesus so vicious like can't catch that
one this is too much too much for
Candyman have that giant gator tail
situation nice try I saw it coming it
was the Gatman can do this Gat G Gatman
G latch gatorman L Gat can do that like
wallat the the skateboard dude can
skateboard all he can go he canot
skateboard dude can go up the walls and
across the ceiling I don't believe lanch
can go up to the scene do we want a
rematch or you want to switch sure I'm
good Candyman is my man run it back
candy man run it back the salty run
backest first uh yeah first win goes to
Maxwell in this Maxwell versus
Tay two pretty strong fgc type
dudes I hear the noise and I'm like oh
no
candy man just candied
lat great ball control here get with the
c in the C mode just can't defend
against that so difficult to predict
where it's going to
come okay so this is something Maxwell
was trying to explain to me earlier uh
crap so there's the gradient bar at the
yeah yeah yeah so you guys will be able
to see this better than I was when I was
playing it once the hits start getting
like super charged you'll notice it
takes longer and longer for the from
point of contact to ball release the
little Rainbow uh EQ bars on the on the
bottom like if you look right to my
right here right between us on the boom
box those see it fills up and boom it
releases so that's getting like that can
be an asset for you trying to predict
when to do your counter hits especially
on those super charged up hits like he
knows it's going to come off
him ooh nice carry there Jesus Cy Cy man
he's got a little bit of his own
medicine oh that didn't catch you got it
twice
ooh I got this slow
swing oh latch down to his last one
candy man I'm get rock in this
match
uh so for those of you who aren't
watching at twitch.tv/ Gamespot where
you got a chat there with reptile games
the developers of Letha League are in
there answering some questions so for
example they are uh targeting Team
Battle online matches single player
challenge mode and CPU matches for the
final sort of modes uh for lethal League
here uh they're going to be aiming to
release in August of this year
um and that's is not a green light
situation it's not a they're just doing
it they're just releasing a game believe
you can just release a fin G release
games when they're done it's like you
make a game and then you're done making
the game and then you and then you
release it and then you put it out and
people
compl uh all right here the rubber match
for Maxwell versus Tay and uh they're
even after four
rounds getting pretty
heated it Dam it damn it damn it get
candy there so so much candy up in this
game right now Cur ban of my existence
oh oh nice catch coming in so quick and
the you just dunked him too to end the
round oh
crap ooh you caught it
nice Max I know have to Gator it up here
gatorman lch come backat we shall
see
that's the candy Perry got stolen
again shh what am I doing oh it's like
that yeah look I got to I got to take
what I can
get no I got to let the ball come to me
I can't chase it as as latch get out of
here lot of lot of discussion in the
chat about about whether uh oh by the
way GG T taking it out Styles good game
nice work all right let's add another
Challenger new house get in there okay
I'm playing three new and who let's see
some three
player we're doing some three should we
try some three freefor all we do a
little three free for all three for
all stick with latch or maybe I'll go to
son all discussion in the uh twitch chat
about teabagging and the ability to do
that here the equivalent is once once
they get knocked out they turn into that
white outlined character this help and
you can just SWAT them away yeah cuz
they don't they don't their little
character icons don't land on the ground
for you to then run over and teabag upon
yeah so I like it because it it's a you
know it's a non gendered uh way to uh
rub it in your opponent's face and stay
l oh my goodness this is
wild oh oop I forgot let him go in the
too excited about his own swaged docious
who who is
blue okay Alex is yellow yeah charge it
up there buddy nice oh why jump into
that get some oh great Parry oh so that
is we did see Sonata special move there
but I know I'm not sure how to they said
something about being able to redirect
ball in midair I'm not 100% on how you
uh how you actually do that
whoa so nasty all right it's so nasty
Candyman special move is ridiculous so
nasty all right I'm blue
position ah what is the skater boys I
have never done a special move yet
switches oh switch is a kick flip you
just kind of jam on the x button once
you hit oh that's the thing okay switch
can actually do his special move anytime
he wants he doesn't have to be making
contact with the ball like the other
character
like
oh like if you just start jamming on it
now get DED on you like jump up and you
do some sort of a kick flip will it will
it impact the ball if he not touching
the ball yeah the kick flip will will
intercept the ball no but like you said
he can do it anytime not just when he's
touching the ball yeah what what you
mean by you like well you know how like
with with latch he needs to be hitting
the ball in order to swallow it
yes switch doesn't have to be hitting
the ball he can just do kick
does it give him like an extra is it
like a movement thing as well then maybe
oh yeah I can dou
jum oh wow that was embarrassing
terrible swing by the skateboarding
robot all right we're all pretty
close all right well now we're
not do die for Sonata in this
round O and it's get from Candyman a
little
better well well there we
go forun swing for the Candyman Chris
you want to get back in yeah yeah I'll
get Cy man is too much oh listen C we
have controllers we don't need to oh we
all no I'm just saying we don't if you
want to drop out you can drop out you
just don't need to pass the controller
I'll drop out for this you don't want to
Lu sweats Lu sweats you want to steal my
power I'm little warm in here guys
getting a little hot all right take it
in oh I'm in yeah all right I got these
eyelashes going on you guys know I
situation have an eyelash situation over
here all right man you can fight candy
with candy right now go ahead just do
all candy mans just do it just do just
do all C hold on there we go too much
candy here we go oh differentiate myself
you're the white Tu you tu that's good I
got to remember which one I am all right
I'm I'm I'm the white and green one all
right well this is the first time ever
playing candy man this
is already going
swell get it that was weird that was C
oh no that was mine which which candy
man's witch I'm the red candy man I Am
The Tuxedo candy man oh two CHR CH did
you just win that yes won both so Chris
is red candy man wait yeah I've won
you know what's weird though is like
when you hit your candy man special it
turned white green like or green we're
going in nightmare mode we're going into
nightmare
mode oh there's so much nightmare mode
happening oh my God what is
happening I was just hiding countering
the nightmare big special taking us into
nightmare mode I am getting rocked I
cannot so Chris is the red candy man
Eric K is playing black and white candy
man oh CRA and I'm getting absolutely
destroyed okay so Alex is black and
white Candyman Eric is the other candy
with green highlights white suit green
highlights is Eric oh that got me what
so now it's down to Chris as red and
Alex as black and white we need to do
some work Alex we're black and white now
has full meter you can go into full
crazy there we go oh why did I jump up
to get it I should have just let it run
cyman cheating mode has been
activated oh de here it comes here it
comes oh but he goes for the straight
back and forth oh taking us into
nightmare
mode why did I jump into that Happ cuz
we were both trying to remember to watch
the bars watch the bars it fills up in
those situations that's true it'll help
your timing I was just going off my feel
I was going that gain
feel
oh it's going by okay that makes sense
oh wow that slam dunk slam dunk air T
clean house Dam dam oh look at that I I
never did his jump he's got like a
little oh he's got like a little butt
flop oh
crap dang it
advant situ these Underdog these dirty
tactics this is just oh crap just caugh
the disrespect is what it was it was the
disrespect get candy feel it oh God I'm
out oh d digly d dir all right life a
piece Chris and Eric Chris is red candy
man Eric the character who just got
shot my swing went before the ball who's
the king of candy who's the candy mate
going taking him the Candy Land right
now king of king of Candy Castle you
interesting though like when you did
your super mhm it actually looked like
my face it was like green but but I
think it's because you're green player
so then I was like oh that's mine and I
was like oh no it's green
players cuz you had the green suit as
opposed to but you were the red color oh
so we were kind of swapped that was a
little made a little tricky for us
that's cool oh you can keep juggling
corpses excellent you can oh yes okay
good to know you can keep if you like
don't hit them straight up Parry Parry
also works on The Jug yeah oh I see all
right let's uh man's just so good but I
want to I got I want to try to mix it up
a little bit here swiy try to play
sonana I like
sonana ghost ghostly base ballman you
want to get in here Max or are we going
to go we're going do four four four
player thr in the four four player is
gross all right let's try a gross match
and then we can uh maybe do like a
little little turn
turny all right uh do we also want to
kick it up to 11 and turn off ball
tagging no okay not yet
this is our first four player match hold
on hold on which we we didn't do that
one yet we haven't seen the PO yet no we
did do the pool sorry we it does look
like a kitchen let's do
we and I fought this one we did fight in
the I like this cuz this one unlike the
other stages is super small get off so
you have no room to
maneuver oh I'm just in between oh my
goodness cleaning that was not a good
place to be
who's blue what's up oh my goodness what
is just chain
him I'm styling switch with that
style who's yellow so far not digging
sonana
oh so hard to like so hard the timing is
so weird now that we're in small spaces
does the meter also like cuz once it's
like it impacts mhm
woo ah I missed it nice you caught it oh
nice cleaned it
up
Hyundai so
chaotic yeah so much much chaos oh oh
here it
comes why oh no we're sounding the alarm
the sirens are going God there's a
breakout that was nasty where am I oh I
jumped into
that into the Dome of the Parry hit a
home run all right Crouch I got to
crouch in this situation get off oh my
goodness apparently you get stunned a
little bit oh I was hitting
a I call
Shenanigans Shin Mami nanigans Shin Mami
nanigans or
golden no o situation oh that was yeah
that was
terrible just so everyone knows I'm
switch uh Maxwell is L latch Sonata and
Raptor Chris Waters I'm the baseball man
I
was this has
been on 60
Minutes and we
return o she
intercepts full meter
oh
a come on Hammer
girl tata looking to make it happen One
Life to two over switch now all tied up
just like that this is it this is here
we go skateboarding robot versus Hammer
girl looking to make per around she
stand right on the robot this is
dangerous very
dang time to react got to look at the
meters really just went in there hoping
for it but uh strong play by everybody
Maxwell hit literally zero people in
that Harry is a lot less useful in this
small room with everyone's swinging I
know Perry pretty much just gives it to
somebody else dangerous all right so
same characters I'm still yeah I'm still
the baseball man
Raptor kick fit that thing
oh Dam it yeah you don't want to par you
don't want to Parry on this got greedy I
was like you can get your
Parry oh my goodness I got hit by the
slowest baseball ever cleaning them up
get him
out oh you hey hey all of you get off
look we all go for drilled for we all go
for it at the start like surely it's in
my
possession oh see like the the time of
impact
it yeah like he got like be there be oh
dang it gatorman got
waffled oh God I don't know what's
happening but I don't like it I don't
like
it I'm a little confused about what who
is doing a what now Max like screw this
be up here you guys need me oh oh man I
did not watch the
oh I kicked the wrong way oh look who
got a win it was me it was me tactical I
like it was Gary Gatman Gary
gaterman got my next level Esports going
D I got punched into
it still find a
time oh nasty nasty nasty I got to start
parrying people one toally be oh crap we
got to take out Raptor oh why oh Raptor
yeah baseball gy
like
this oh I gave it to
him the pic turn on the Panic
Room oh wow all right well I'm out oh
son of a serving up these Harries and
they are definitely oh I missed it I
missed it how did you miss
it oh that timing ouch such
time
what not going down I'm not going down
there F I'll come up to you I'm going
coming up to
you latch is out too it comes down to
switch and Raptor oh Chris and classic
matchup switch and Raptor switch pull it
off do you want it
Raptor Raptor going to workmo get him
out oh nightmare
mode Mega Man has been unlocked oh
Flavor in Your Ear let's go let's dude
I'm digging baseball man baseball man
base ballman B bman his special move is
just like a double swing basically and
it hits it it just ramps up the speed
really fast it's when you spins like in
a hurricane right or whatever or a
tornado so one thing that might be
interesting and I don't know this may be
terrible but I want to try it out the
ball tagging is no not ball actually not
ball tagging uh let's uh let's do Max
ball speed five oh man what was it a
default 10K what was a default it yeah
it was like 10K all right so let's see
uh let's see what happens see how this
goes it might be
terrible could be here's a quick fun
fact from the devs uh Jet Set Radio was
a inspiration for character design I can
I can see
that seen that
slow I don't know but it's not picking
up any speed so this is like the opening
movement speed of the ball this
is
both have special moves where to
go am I just like really floaty in the
air is that what candy man oh are you
canon in yeah I'm canon
in yeah it's not really getting a lot
faster seems like the same speed yeah it
just doesn't increase in speed which I
don't know takes away from I know I do
not know about that
like that Parry smash feeling
it see you see you see
you dang it see
you
B up top Parts stying styl stop points
you're playing as
Mega Man yeah that delay really delay
when they when when it KO someone else
and then you're coming in on it yeah
that
oh stuck in a bad place oh see that that
just I was striking a character off the
screen and then got hit by the ball
while was happening hey hey hey red B I
always for it uh-oh uh-oh he spits it
out gobbl it up oh L just B of people
right now where did it happen where did
it go I looked on the screen and there
was no ball I ate it I at oh wow I'm man
I'm not too great oh that was a mistake
come back switch right here oh yeah epic
come back you're just proclaiming it
before it happens yep all
right someone takes switch out so uh we
not have to see this epic for the not
the first guy outward on this round
there we go not first guy out here we go
oh a dome this baseball helmet does
nothing o now I
am double down doubling down that's
called a rush down is Wrecking rapt
Chris bring those Rush down strats I
think Chris found his coach of choice
right put it back in your M oh no what
was going on there oh I don't know how L
was able to keep up with raptor on all
those hits
but I guess your Super move doesn't
really do a whole lot for you Raptor in
this circumstance cuz the ball just
isn't going to go
Fastow can we up the speed even more we
knocked it down that time yeah let's
take a look at the the other the
Spectrum yeah all right everybody don't
hit but let's take a look at so it goes
1 million million 1 million milon let's
go for it we'll go for 1 mil this is all
still good okay reptile games on that
one said activate boring
mode so why is it in there then huh I
guess it would be good if we if we had
played that to start with while we were
all learning it would have been a good
learning teaching tool cuz it's not so
crazy we just jumped in a 10 10K dude so
we're we just WI 100 times faster so now
it's going to go like a bazillion
million times faster my goodness this is
going to be wild this is going to be
insane I mean it still it's the max
speed though so it still has to build up
to that
point oh I got to hit we oh here we go
here we go oh God we're already in
nightmare mode we're already in
nightmare mode wow we went nightmare
real quick it feel faster it went it
went to nightmare pretty quick it went
there faster
what I scooped
you intercepted dang cuz I got these emo
jeans
on why was I there I don't know why I
thought that would be a good
idea obviously wasn't I think Chris
found his
character oh oh here we go slam that's
right oh no oh no no no B SE
B oh my
goodness fa it oh [__] no get away from
there oh my God I'm not doing on the
switch
anymore oh God oh my oh you know what it
was I think it cuz of the it hit it hit
Chris
first oh
my might want to go up there and yeah I
got it okay
Jesus Oh Jes here it comes
here why don't don't even go up there
it's fine no
slam my
godom let it happen to my face wanted
know part of that oh son of a me are you
serious Thanks Max I justed I expected
you to do something you know what I
kamakazi it cuz I just I let myself get
hit so that you would impact my body
oh God I cannot catch it I got I got to
start teing more oh
God never mind things are bad things are
bad down there things are getting real
bad Candyman one hit away here it comes
here it comes the C man
special I thought I had it
l wow all right all right damn it the
temptation to smack dead Alex was too
strong oh [__] no come on candy man
cleaning
up man what's up
girl
baseballs what do you think about my
baseballs uh appar that's what I think
that's what we call a good WIN Job WIN
Job oh that's what we call a total choke
move Raptor let you even pulled out oh
the Parry into the okay what Bam Bam the
trick against Chris is to hit it slow
the rap Dynasty get
got Chris Chris got the reactions but
when it's so slow it throws throws his
game off I know I think we should do
some teams we should you want to do some
teams uh yeah t do you want to do the
team let do the candy or we got to be
the same color right can you do that
though can you do the same character in
the same I don't think you can I'll go
swi character not let you do it doesn't
look oops similar characters on I don't
think so cuz like there's only one color
for that wait rightt oh yeah I you're
you're player two right Maxwell I am so
we're two the Hyundai
Sonata team blue team blue you got the
blue shirt I got the blue shirt blue
team te I got the red shirt so yeah red
team that means some orange Alex Captain
yeah that's what that means means randos
oh God I like how we're playing each
other's supposed main
character
all right let's go candy y here we go
here we go and possession I didn't get
it oh God nice oh you got this stay SPAC
down stay SPAC
down power
nice give it to him some more give it to
him some more catch it again yes candy
team red team red team candy team
red sure Candy in here right now oh I
got I so that was the first time that I
got I clashed strikes with another
player and got I got hit back oh you got
stunned from the from the flash strike
and then it messed up your
timing nice you getting not going Team
all right all right all right all right
bring it back bring it back nice now I
catch yours yes you catch mine oh I'll
catch
my oh crap oh welcome to the Panic Room
welcome to the Panic Room get paniced
get
panic get panic get C we cannot get
goose egg here this is not
acceptable shut down shut out B get a
little bit of this right now all right
oh wow I'm out take it badly you didn't
get Bagel all right no Bagel here wow I
would have have thought you for a one-on
one I think I clash with you on that
one nice catch
CCH this is not
pretty I suggest a change a venue
Raptor oh total failure that time around
oh yeah all day doing a sick kick that
was bad no no change menu team red team
red insist Change menu all right you
think that's going to save
you Sonata she needs she needs room to
breathe okay got room to breathe we just
got team
newbie there's a clash that a clash hey
guys what's going on I want to play a
baseball game hey yeah yeah yeah do that
so every time he swings you should clash
him to strategize so oh crap I'm out oh
let's keep juggling
him all right well yeah so
that
goodness boom get candied all
right
oh you got this you catch it again yeah
it's raining it's raining Maxwell you
stood in there I I thought I was far
enough into his character model that it
wouldn't impact me but it that was not
the
case
nice snipe It Like It's
Hot oh crap oh crap got his Lo and he
sent me
flying see you later
nards o nice pair no it's his PA on me
yeah I know
so oh wow okay the nightmare Zone oh
it's over oh nice it
no get it it is it over we're in the Nee
it was in the
Nee too much God damn
it oh get bodied ah get bodied Eric I
got bodied I got bed I
got oh I couldn't land fast
enough this is it
Maxwell oh I
got oh
nice
oh let it
go and he finish him off insult to
injury oh
candy look at that on top of the m tried
to go for the duck why not oh Maxwell
and I getting worked
by and new
house we trying again Maxim what's our
what's our strategy here need I'm got
I've been opening a lot with me in the
corner that never seems to work out they
always immediately hit it into me so I'm
going to try to stay more in the center
of the map this
time instead of Hing the corners man
they've got the pares
down that didn't work that did not work
work trying to go in quick quick
intercept oh nice way to get him off the
field a
damn oh my goodness who is the robot
skater that's me that's Eric never heard
of him oh
sh oh wow what was going on there St
juggling his dead body power juggled got
some body com yeah get some rain get
some rain make rain rain maker over here
calls for Cloudy Skies son of a
blur how did you catch that oh he
caught oh damn I'm not going to get that
screw that you're going
to what you got what you that's fine
what you got I'm okay with it that is
okay
nice oh that's not nope try to catch it
did not work
nope all right keep it up keep it up
Sonata got a lot
of
NOP got
it catch that nice nice nice oh
wow see you later getting real crazy my
nightmares new house oh no we're falling
apart no
nice
nice watching those keep hitting her
keep hitting
her oh that oh wow oh just oh man Cy
want to set that
one
oh my goodness Candyman is
out take to the yeah let's go to it oh
get taking yourself oh here we go that
was going to be it Oh I thought that was
oh the kick flips we're going to the
nightmare
Zone oh [__] just me baby all
right Ain no stay on either side of
them not work that didn't work maxw well
it's all you all right
no I didn't catch it Hyundai Sonata
versus the Kia switch
Hyundai intercept it fast enough to stop
you from Catching away got Dr lat that
was a much better match I was that was a
good well very well played well
met more which character is it uh yeah
quit quit out I want to mix up my
character I think three you going I have
never played I feel like
I guess I'll be I'll do I'll try Raptor
just be oh wait we have to be
blue red blue CR actually forget that I
want to be Swit that's right we're
switch Candyman team you guys are go
with strong play God I mean all right at
least we're bringing some
character I don't know what variety your
your strong character is Raptor too so I
mean I'm not playing as rap I'm playing
as
Croc yeah I'm r for just so it's not
confusing well nice yeah you like nice
Corner
pressure oh man raptor is so much faster
dude I'm not used to candyman's
jump I am a [__]
crocodile what happened where am I
I at first I was confident that I was a
crocodile but then I wasn't so sure I
need to start up my game
here oh
ah nice time
it hey guys oh my God what's happening
in this corner over here you guys want a
crocodile at your party life of the
party crocodile was a success I don't
even want to go in there
wow the advantage of being the character
with like the fastest freaking slam oh
my goodness man we we should go back to
our old strategy I can just go hang out
in the corner and just mash the xeg
button
apparently cing it oh
what it and lock it slowly but surely oh
my
God Richard let me down rock and lock
you need to yell Betty Crocker when you
uh
okay hey guys oh it's not a good scene
just party I don't know why see you
later alligator oh hi what's going on
you guys uh you guys play the game oh my
gator
head oh the sick
Parry
slam
duck oh
Candyman a he took you to the candy shop
yeah he took he took me to King of the
castle I don't think so do not go C
easily that good
night was there the was
there wait I was looking at the
chat
[__] oh nice all right we got this we
got a a long waye yes we do oh I'm I'm
out oh that was
you oh
gosh
oh oh what this it's my
baseball and out of control you know
what happened I hit Max's body oh did
you I hit Max's body right when you hit
it I was like I got this oh no that was
nice though damn inter is there anything
further than that like does it does it
does it glitch out even more than that
so what he told me I asked him if
there's anything beyond like negative
nightmare mode and he said what'll
happen is if you hit it faster than that
it throws up all these gra graphical
glitches is on the screen and the screen
will start to break and like tear and
stuff so we haven't gotten there yet we
haven't gotten to that point yet but
that's like that's like the highest that
was your free one for losing here I I I
just died there we go yeah I did too
there you
go no never works never works I went
with the cool take a nap move but uh
that didn't work
so no I didn't catch it handyman caught
it ah I carried it into him nice use my
body
boom use my body use my dead body get
nightmared a I got The Clash hit on that
one again by Robo
donkey he looks like a donkey
y insulting his
Heritage ah nice clearing it out I can
run pretty fast for an alligator you
guys I just don't know
that oh wow thank you can't if you guys
want to talk alligator land speed real
quick not the
creat oh kick
CED
no couldn't catch it couldn't
escalate trying
to
nice that was nice oh God Gary gatorman
oh hit it oh oh God right on the tip you
just the
tip St
Harry oh he's just going crazy my
goodness uhoh uhoh oh my
God Nega Zone keep
going that was that was
crazy oh what these clashes are this I'm
definitely so there is it's like once
you get to this sort of super high level
of playing that we're at after playing
for an hour yeah once you there is
definitely like
a The Bard yeah of actually hitting the
other player becomes a little bit more
all right we just have to kill rap let's
do it oh wait I'm out yep you got
cheated on that one straight up oh just
keep catch keep catching it oh yeah you
catch it now you catch it you're a
maniac yeah now I'll catch it now you
catch
it now I'll catch
it yeah oh he should have hit his body
yeah nice little high kick there strong
match strong match strong match new
stage all right I think this is going to
be our last is this close to our last
face off cuz we got about five should we
go same characters I don't know it's up
to you well we mix it up mix it up I'll
try Raptor I'll try I'll try
baseball the baseball action here all
right what does that
mean which Gator candy man candy candy
man you know what we're going to
do turn off that ball tag oh no man okay
so anything can the ball will always
hurt you it is always a hazard you
always want to avoid it or hit it righta
or hit yeah you can also hit it as you
normally would okay remember that you
always want to be hitting the ball dude
so that means we can we can there's
friendly fire then obviously I guess so
I guess it doesn't really matter that
we're on
teams okay
all right I'm
out yeah got killed my ball yeah I just
I'll just not die how about that oh you
just going to play this neutral
game this is this is oh wow hit by
myself woo let me just duck it let me
just uh here my God you were the worst
you were the worst person don't worry
about me you the worst person
Eric I got me but you also got your
teammate
oh candy oh here it comes oh wow okay I
was like is it going to hit
him candy
man give me that give me some of that
candy I just got hit by myself yeah yeah
that's what the no ball tagging is oh wa
not playing attention we Alex I wasn't
I'm sorry I don't know why fine I should
have just got out of the way I also
should have gotten out of the way oh
crap
just get away from it hide in the
corner yeah kill yourself did you see
that yeah you like that you like that
straty you like that strategy you see
how it worked you see how it
worked don't knock it don't get in my
corner Oh
no I got
T T got good survival instincts I just
got straight
slaughtered oh got me behind there no
ball go clean not being nice to me oh
watch
out watch
out see you later candy man that's fine
that's fine the double whammy that
double whammy oh wow oh that's not wor
I'm
out is the worst we go Don't Mind If I
Do is crazy yeah I'm just going to avoid
it [__] slash jump right into it yeah
very true let's go
Raptor Oh no I got this is it one on one
one life left this is it one life hide
the most One Life to Live who can the
most not run into their own ball
oh
anticlimax as Tay goes down blue team
wins I'm not feeling that let's do one
more got you want to turn off put please
put it back on please no B
can we please want to back off is back
on we got our speeds up want switch your
character I I
know C oh oh okay it's okay wait no we
should have done candy team oh come have
some sweets oh you guys figur how to do
the Candy Crush over have some sweets
all right I no Raptor
Sonata Che Big League Chew Styles Big
League Chew Big League Chew I'm shred
you and I'm going chew you that in a
long time and I'm going to put like just
a giant wad of it in my mouth and spit
it behind the B St yeah just stop oh wow
candy 2 is
out I'm like so scared of the ball now
cuz we were playing with ball hanging on
nice get that
meter feel it take him to the Auto Zone
nice try feel
it oh got
me nice take him to the candy
shop get him out get him out sweep
it clear the
bases or baseball
metaphors
so candy that candy man candy for
everybody oh candy it's really difficult
it's a difficult situation it is quite
challenging to uh extricate yourself
from
yeah
nice oh nice carry oh but he gave it
what how did it come off your bat going
crazy crazy how did that come off your
bat so quick I don't know see that's why
I don't understand
sometimes oh I got this one bu don't you
wor oh I got it again friends oh you
want some
more oh my
I think I just super swung your body I I
think you did I used my I think that was
the ultimate style as the ultimate way
to styl in some body look at this Raptor
Corner nonsense by the way wow is so
crazy in the corner you cannot deal he
hits it so fast oh gosh I'm I'm not not
in the mood for all that whatever that
was I don't know just not not feeling
not feeling oh wow all
right that was a mistake somebody had
that breed Cy man got that sweet too
yep
hello Dam candy man we got to come back
uh yeah we do why did I go in there I
know I do it all the time it never works
NOP carrying the ball and then trying to
go get
it all right you got this oh no I was
looking the wrong
way not to die though I
know
nice oh jeez oh jeez send him into the
nightmare Zone oh Jesus we're going in
the nightmare nightmare over
time get in the Zone Auto
Zone oh it's mine no no it's
not we got glitch this we got to glitch
the crap out of
it that's okay I came in I came would
have been good if we got to a Kill
screen wow all right well I'm out okay
you got this cand
one a oh my goodness this is going to be
rough they both have three lives all
right oh my
goodness flop and
Bop bounce silly little candy
Dome want to escalate you want you want
to escalate you don't want to escalate a
nice work guys like fig it out it's like
they leveled up during we were like
destroying them and then I think the
double candy Manch that was not soart no
I I was not playing Candyman well that
time googly eyes like I feel like my
eyes are googly you feel googly yeah
you're feeling pretty goog yeah you're
pretty Googled right now oh yeah that oh
that was tight as
hell Max thank you for bringing this
game in uh he's got a little write up on
it but you folks just learn so much
about lethal League uh thanks so much to
reptile games for being in the twitch
chat and answering a ton of questions
games coming out in August on Steam keep
an ey for that uh you guys candy men
well fought but uh blue team carries the
day yeah and uh goes I mean that's
that's lethal League any final words
gentlemen it's a good time it's a fun
game ton of
fun good times and yeah
like as Alex and I were sort of talking
before as we were like scrub League guys
not not that like don't play fighting
games as much as like these Aces on the
corners but it's you figured it out you
figured out right and it's it's a lot
more about positioning than like knowing
any kind of move set yeah there's no
like crazy 20 button combos you got to
remember anything so all that crazy crap
you're just watching super accessible
very cool game lethal League thanks for
watching this is multiple players see
you next week 2 pm
Pacific